si hacemos incidir luz infrarroja sobre
una molécula es posible que la molécula
absorba esa energía y eso puede provocar
que un enlace se estire a eso se le
conoce como vibración de estiramiento
aunque existen otros tipos por ahora
solo nos enfocaremos en el estiramiento
la vibración de estiramiento de un
enlace es como la oscilación de un
resorte imaginemos que este enlace entre
el carbono y el hidrógeno es un resorte
este es nuestro resorte de un lado
tenemos al carbono y del otro tenemos al
hidrógeno entonces tenemos un resorte
con una masa en cada extremo y si
aplicamos energía podemos estirar el
resorte es decir que podemos jalar el
carbono hacia este lado y el hidrógeno
hacia este
si estiramos el resorte pero sabemos que
los resortes también se contraen así que
el resorte puede regresarse en esta
dirección y así obtenemos una oscilación
es decir la vibración de estiramiento de
un enlace echemos un vistazo al espectro
infrarrojo para esta molécula estamos
hablando del 1 oct y no si hacemos pasar
radiación infrarroja a través de una
muestra de este compuesto una parte es
absorbida y podemos saber qué
frecuencias fueron absorbidas si
analizamos el espectro infrarrojo aquí
tenemos algunos números como 3000 o 4000
que representan las frecuencias
luminosas y de este lado tenemos el
porcentaje de la radiación transmitida
también conocida como transmitancia por
ejemplo si tenemos el 100% de
transmitancia y tenemos esta frecuencia
luminosa
si subimos en el espectro hasta llegar
al 100% el 100% de la transmitancia
significa que toda la luz o radiación
fue transmitida a través de la muestra y
si toda la luz fue transmitida entonces
nada fue absorbido así que esta
frecuencia en particular no fue
absorbida por el compuesto pero si
hablamos de un porcentaje menor al 100%
de la transmitancia por ejemplo en esta
frecuencia aparece una señal y significa
que no toda la luz fue transmitida no
tenemos el 100% de transmitancia así que
un poco de esta energía a esta
frecuencia fue absorbida por la molécula
y eso puede provocar un estiramiento de
enlace hay vibración de estiramiento
esta señal corresponde al enlace que les
mencionaba entonces esta señal indica
el estiramiento de este enlace
ahora ya hablamos del porcentaje de
transmitancia pero hablemos del número
de onda a estos números les he llamado
frecuencias luminosas pero veamos cómo
es que el número de onda se relaciona
con la frecuencia y la longitud de onda
el número de onda es igual a 1 entre la
longitud de onda dada en centímetros por
ejemplo si tenemos una longitud de onda
igual a 0.00 dos centímetros cuál es el
número de onda usemos la calculadora
tenemos uno entre 0.002 esto es igual a
500 el número de onda es igual a 500 y
está dado en uno en tres centímetros que
también lo podemos escribir como
centímetros a la menos uno
este es el número de onda si regresamos
al espectro podemos ver que el número de
onda igual a 500 corresponde a una
longitud de onda en particular y esto se
relaciona con la frecuencia porque
recordemos que la longitud de onda por
la frecuencia lambda por nu es igual a
la velocidad de la luz ce y si
despejamos la frecuencia no es igual a
la velocidad de la luz entre la longitud
de onda y esto es igual a 1 entre lambda
por la velocidad de la luz pero ya
dijimos que uno entre lambda es igual al
número de onda así que la frecuencia es
igual al número de onda por la velocidad
de la luz hagamos este cálculo tomando
esta longitud de onda que nos dio este
número de onda vamos a sustituirlo aquí
y veamos que obtenemos
el número de onda es 500 dado en 1 /
centímetros por la velocidad de la luz
que en centímetros es aproximadamente
igual a 3 por 10 a la 10 centímetros
entre segundos y observen que los
centímetros se cancelan usemos la
calculadora tenemos el número de onda y
lo multiplicamos por la velocidad de la
luz en centímetros es decir 3 por 10 a
la 10 esto es igual a 1.5 por 10 a la 13
la frecuencia es igual a 1.5 por 10 a la
13 y las unidades nos quedan como 1 /
segundo o lo podemos expresar como hartz
entonces el número de onda es la inversa
de la longitud de onda y con eso también
podemos obtener la frecuencia voy a
reescribir lo rápidamente la frecuencia
es igual al número de onda
por la velocidad de la luz por lo tanto
el número de onda es igual a la
frecuencia entre la velocidad de la luz
esta es la ecuación que usaremos en los
siguientes vídeos entonces la frecuencia
es directamente proporcional al número
de onda regresemos a nuestro espectro en
el eje x tenemos el número de onda que
también puede ser la frecuencia pueden
llamarle como más les guste mientras
entiendan lo que es pero analicemos con
más detalle el espectro infrarrojo
dibujaré una línea en el número de onda
igual a 1500 para dividir el espectro en
dos regiones la región de la izquierda
se conoce como región de diagnóstico
esta es la región de diagnóstico se le
llama así porque las señales que
aparecen en esta región pueden servir
como diagnóstico para detectar un cierto
grupo funcional por ejemplo esta señal
que se
encuentra aproximadamente en un número
de onda igual a 2100 corresponde al
triple enlace así que esto nos dice que
hay un grupo funcional presente en este
caso por eso se dice que es un
diagnóstico además nos ayuda a conocer
la estructura de la molécula así que en
un espectro y rr podemos identificar la
presencia de diferentes grupos
funcionales ahora la región del lado
derecho se conoce como huella dactilar
es muy difícil interpretar esta región
porque no es tan fácil identificar las
diferentes señales sin embargo esta
región es única para cada molécula por
eso se dice que es como una huella
dactilar así que cuando tenemos un
compuesto desconocido pero tenemos el
espectro y r podemos analizar esta
región que lo identifica cada una de
estas líneas
son únicas para cada molécula entonces
tenemos la región de diagnóstico y la
huella dactilar no entraremos mucho en
la región de huella dactilar pero nos
enfocaremos en la región de diagnóstico
y analizaremos las señales cada señal
aparece en un número de onda específico
por lo que la localización de la señal
es muy importante para este vídeo cambie
un poco los espacios del número de onda
pero no hay problema igualmente dibuje a
mano el espectro así que no está
perfecto pero la idea es que no se
preocupen tanto por la escala lo
importante son las señales como por
ejemplo esta señal que se encuentra
aproximadamente en un número de onda
igual a 2100 también tendremos que tomar
en cuenta la intensidad y la forma de la
señal hablaremos más sobre eso en los
siguientes vídeos en el siguiente vídeo
desarrollaremos un poco más light
hace que los enlaces son como resortes y
hablaremos un poco de física clásica